a menos de un mes de las últimas
elecciones legislativas en Italia este
sábado se llevó a cabo el juramento del
nuevo gobierno italiano Georgia melón y
la líder del partido de ultraderecha
posfacista hermanos de Italia da así
inicio a su mandato junto con un
gabinete de 24 ministros 18 hombres y
seis mujeres entre los que se destacan
Antonio tallani ex presidente del
parlamento europeo nombrado canciller y
Vice Primer Ministro también Mateo
salvín y líder del partido de
ultraderecha la liga nombrado vicepre
Primer Ministro y ministro de
infraestructuras otro dirigente de la
liga Jean Carlos giorgetti estará al
frente del Ministerio de economía se
trata del gobierno más derechista en
Italia desde la Segunda Guerra Mundial y
Georgia melón y nacida en Roma hace 45
años se convierte en la primera mujer al
poder en la historia democrática de
Italia deberá afrontar numerosos
desafíos el control de las finanzas
públicas en un país profundamente
endeudado la lucha contra el desempleo y
la administración del fondo de
recuperación europeo Italia es el estado
que más dinero europeo va a recibir unos
200 mil millones de euros en préstamos y
subvenciones otorgados a Italia por
parte de la Unión Europea a cambio de
llevar a cabo un programa ambicioso de
reformas